so I'm an early riser and there's two
tasks I had that morning the first was
we had recently purchased a puppy so
this says so so it shortly after five
o'clock that morning I I took the dog
out for a walk and then because I'm
supposed to I regularly exercise shortly
after six o'clock so i was in between I
brought taking the dog for a walk came
back was just thinking about getting
ready to go out and exercise at that
point in time the phone call came in is
this really happening so the first was
well the first indication that this was
a call from Stockholm and the second
person conveyed to be the message about
the award I started to believe it when
the third person kept got on the third
person was someone who who I knew for
for several years and twisted Pearson
and so when he came on to congratulate
me I said wow I guess this has just
happened really happening my wife could
kind of sense that something was
happening so she was in the kitchen so
she quickly came to the kitchen and kind
of witness this and figure it out